they have arrived in Germany the Silva's
are from Portugal they had been living
in hala for a year
Erica will start school in the fall her
mom has already filled out most of the
necessary forms okay so far we haven't
had any problems with bureaucracy then
we have our little apartment erica is
going to go to school so everything's
good it's better better than last year
that's when we met the Silva's as this
residential facility Liliana had been in
Germany for just a few weeks she
practiced her german with colleagues she
had taken a language course back in
Portugal but still had trouble
communicating the young mother
experienced a number of
misunderstandings speaking with
government agencies and filling out
their forms they told me that she could
come here that he had she have a
kindergarten to go but only in September
things are different today Liliana has
finished her first year learning to be a
dental technician she completed her
course on theory all in German I'm
writing in a book
I write down how to do my work in
Portuguese and now in German - I have
everything right here this is my book
Lilliana's colleagues are impressed to
go to a foreign country and start from
scratch I'm sure you would get homesick
and miss your family I don't think it's
very easy the firm has two people from
Portugal on the team already they're
looking to hire more trainees from any
country last year Holly's chamber of
trade helps 21 people from Portugal come
to the city to start an internship 13 of
them are still in school Anika Gabe art
works at the chamber of trade she says
the biggest hurdle for many new arrivals
is learning a new language and being far
away from home sometimes things just
happen like personal problems for
example when something happens to a
family member back in Portugal and
someone has to end their training to go
back home for personal reasons then of
course we can't do anything about that
last year we also visited this
construction site the electrical team
was looking to hire new trainees for
young men from Portugal came for an
internship the boss wanted to find
people for his firm's apprenticeship
program one year later he got them two
of the four interns met the firm's
requirements and decided to start an
apprenticeship at the company
the committee actually thought it would
turn out worse we're really pleased with
the success rate for more are coming
next year now we have to look and see
what happens we're surprised by how well
it's gone Rui Pinheiro
is one of the interns who stayed I have
a job here I have a life here I am
learning a profession that's important
the on-site foreman Ferreira miranda is
also portuguese miranda has lived in
germany for ten years he hopes Carneiro
get situated at his new job while at
work the two men only speak German with
each other it's better to learn German
the more we speak the more we learn
you're both Portuguese and you speak
German with each other exactly so he can
learn fast trainees who can speak German
are in high demand the region of hala
alone has 500 open apprenticeship
positions waiting to be filled